okay so the neighbors say they haven't
seen or heard any activity in the
Buckley's apartment and what is he doing
here
if we find James and he's unstable
doctor take it talking down hello
Peralta plus on the ride over he gave me
a quickie what quick therapy session we
talked about so much did you know that I
have a tendency to be unconsciously
sexual yes so real tough enough to bust
up you're doing it again
no okay I think I hear it you think you
hear it whatever let's just do this okay
NYPD open up it's weird the doors are
locked
that's too bad I love watching you pound
what house Charles what no sexual which
part all of the parts
[Music]
hi this is for you Thanks
quite a big package you got there oh I
apologize for the double entendre I can
be such a Samantha really played work we
saved our own honeymoon and fun bonus we
cheered up holt okay it's time to
celebrate you know what that means
this bee needs a seein her a oh my god
this baby needs a coconut nerds oh I
thought you were saying this music oh my
god that was my reaction all right I'll
go get us a couple of coca tea fine I'll
get my stuff but this better not bite me
in the ass better not bite me in the ass
name of your sex day but seriously thank
you so much variable I told you Jake
I'll do anything to perk up my little
man you've gotta know how gross that
sounds in your underwear so we get our
perp to text the stabbed guy tell him to
hire me to move his product then I show
up grind a bunch of gnarly rails I'm
talking real fluffy ones radical I bet
you're an awesome fluffer yeah I bet you
fluff those are the writers right there
bikers short girls I could picture you
as a teenager fluffing all of New York
City I'll stop talking fluffing has a
different meaning
what are they these madam are STDs what
are you talking about buddy STDs save
the dates for Vivian on my wedding
ah yes hey just out of curiosity how
many people have you given STDs to lots
like a hundred what's going on oh okay I
get it
STD has another meaning you're gross no
one else is gonna think that everyone is
going to think that but it's sweet that
your mind didn't go there thank you it
is kind of sweet well your first dance
beats you you give me fever will you be
seven crabs as the reception the other
Arby's guys this is my wedding this is
important to me
no more jokes you're right and we're
sorry yeah we love you buddy
warts and all sorry I made a rash
decision I was hitching to say it okay
I'm done I have an STD
so just our sleep here yeah the numbers
right on the answers great there it is a
shriveled husk of Raymond Holt look Gina
is that a talking raisin enough Wally
look I know you think my judgments
clouded because I like her a little bit
you doodled your wedding invitation no
that's a hard joint tombstone right a
stick it has a cop I really don't think
that she did it
something's off about the case okay
Boyle I trust your gut
let's go free and innocent woman nice my
dreams are coming true you and me get my
lady off together I mean you know how
that sounds right Gordon you want to
come in here oh I'm so sorry I was just
deciding whether I should just go home
the tone and tenor of your introduction
make me worry that this is a fun office
which I would not enjoy Hey hello I'm
captain Raymond Holt and I can assure
you this is not a fun office thank
goodness
in that case my interest is renewed here
is my resume oh I'm feeling this are you
guys feeling this Gordon why don't you
tell captain Holt a little bit about
yourself where to begin
I'm 174 centimeters tall I can type a
hundred and three words per minute with
an error rate of 1.6% and I recently
moved here from Philadelphia which is a
sixth most populous US city I understand
the city of Philadelphia is coterminous
with Philadelphia County making it the
eighth largest metropolitan statistical
area yeah
Philly's cool isn't it fun just telling
each other facts yes well I think I have
all the information I need thank you for
coming in mr. luck my pleasure
so looks like operation nasty is a
full-on success huh you mean operation
nasties sex life as I know it didn't you
see him flirting with me no I most
definitely did not and you're a blind
man and approved to boot did you see his
tie a single Windsor the easiest not to
undo why bother wearing any clothes at
all I think you badly misread that
interaction please he did everything but
lick his lips and purr get rid of them
and bring to someone who can keep it in
their slacks time to gear up it's not
the best case ever without some toys oh
yeah toys for boys like that adult toys
still sounds wrong male toys you know
what let's just not call them toys
that's my fault I started it you got it
we'll just call playthings we will not
let's do this come on sir the math thing
isn't the problem night shifts keeping
you and Kevin apart you two just need a
bone
I said you two need a bone Oh dare you
detective Diaz I am your superior
officer what happens in my bedroom
detective is none of your business don't
ever speak to me like that again that
dude is pent up no he knows problem
solved
did you know there's a sausage you can
drink sir we need to talk about Gordon
Lunt and before you ask I have not fired
him yes I noticed he's been strutting
around like a peacock trying desperately
to arouse me his unwilling pea head do
you hear there's a barrel making exhibit
at the Brooklyn Museum of Industry yes
has he no shame the door was open I
think he wanted people to hear she is
amazing her palate is wide and deep yes
I'm not gonna let the nightshift win me
and my main man boiler about to solve a
case isn't that right Charles oh you
know we will we'll call ourselves the
night boys kind of sounds like a male
escort service to midnight men even
worse the dark stallions looks like
we're going with the night boys Santiago
I've been your CEO for four years by now
you should be able to stand up for
yourself
even if that means telling me off you're
right just say the word and I will tell
you off okay tell me off about losing
your pin oh right now okay
well makes me feel pretty annoyed good
no it grates my cheese I mean it just
really grates my cheese
Oh Santiago you faking faking what did
you hear that girl just admitted weight
buying I was faking the whole time but I
only did it because I wanted you to
enjoy it that ruins it it's supposed to
be good for both of us it was good just
because I didn't get angry doesn't mean
I didn't get anything out of it
but the whole point is for you to get
angry did you even get close what about
your last CEO could you make your anger
do you know what I don't want to know
don't tell me I don't want to know I'm
working on a thing where when I'm out of
ammo I released my mag
and drop to get straight to someone's
throat oh my buttholes Wow okay I know
you have two bullet wounds in your butt
but you got to stop calling them your
buttholes and your thought they're gonna
let you see that's good cuz yes
Oh mr. guitar oh good to see you can we
talk to Rosa for a quick sec about some
super serious police work I know what
you're trying to do you brought him in
here to butter him up yeah and I've been
laying it on real men okay but you're
making a big mistake
nobody sucks up like a boil of course
you knew that already because you're so
smart I just did it to you oh I know man
bring it okay looks like you and I are
in a good old-fashioned suck off
don't call it a suck off why not wash
and oh yeah yeah yeah yeah totally yep
hmm right smart good hey there Boyle how
was your weekend well actually I got a
little sick oh really
sorry to hear that man yeah bullets over
Broadway was on TV I came down with a
big old Dianne Wiest infection
like there you go
thanks I know just where to put that oh
there's Samantha again Oh captain I know
you don't want to talk about Monty Hall
but I did contact a man no need Santiago
it's all good so the fight with Kevin is
over yep
because you understand the map nope you
guys you guys yep knew it see what
happen is your dad's had sex okay Rosa
hey Rosa are you ready to go shrieking
what that's my dad and I call it getting
blonde streaks in your hair we should do
to our ponytails on road trips you just
take a little lemon up top and let the
Sun do the rest we call that giving each
other road head you just said you called
it going streaking it had a couple names
the plan was for me to weaken your
defenses of my brazen sexuality I
wouldn't say brazen so much is
completely undetectable I couldn't have
been more obvious I wore a single
Windsor knot I might as well have a
signer on my neck that reads DTF
desiring Thoreau fornication no exactly
Oh at first the flirting was just part
of the ruse it meant nothing to me but
then the barrel museum I fell hard not
surprising it is an erotic Lea charged
atmosphere the curve of the slats the
rivets the builds the bunghole okay I'm
actually certainly near the sex talk now
the bunghole is the least erotic part of
the barrel it's simply functional sure
sure sure she's your bunghole continue
this is happening Jake and Amy are
getting married tonight titled my sex
tape yeah ah good morning captain Holt
you're looking refreshed interesting I
didn't sleep a wink let's just say Kevin
no longer has me in the guest room nice
my two dads straight smashing it sorry
that's weird title your estate
you